hi
i'm james malone today i'm here to talk
about what's new in open source data
processing on google cloud
so today i want to talk about six things
i want to talk about
who we are and then i want to talk about
a few key releases that are
really exciting for us dataproc
metastore
dataproc hub some of our open source
updates
a few new features and then how you can
get started using our managed open
source services
on google cloud
first i want to talk about open data
analytics we're a group that's
passionate about combining
google infrastructure with the best of
google cloud
we think that open source represents
many cases the best
of software it's community driven it
moves quickly
it really pushes the envelope of what's
possible
we also think that google cloud can run
infrastructure like
nobody else so we're really interested
in combining
the power of open source and the power
of google's infrastructure to create
managed services so you can use managed
open source
on google cloud we think that open
source should be efficient
secure and accessible
over the last year we've released over
40 releases
and the reason i bring this up is we are
very interested
in keeping up with the open source
community and all of the new releases
but we also want our customers to
rapidly have the latest and greatest in
both
open source and also google cloud
platform features things like
vpc service controls we think the faster
that we can
enable our customers the faster they
have access to the best of both open
source
and google cloud
one of our big new releases that i'm
really excited to talk to you about
today is the dataproc metastore
so i'm going to give you an overview of
what the dataproc metastore is
and why we have developed the dataproc
petastore
the dataproc metastore is essentially a
managed apache hive meta store so i want
to start out with
why the hive metastore is such a big
deal because that drove
why we developed a managed metastore
service in the first place
the apache hive meta stores really as
far as we see it the open standard for
data lakes there's a lot of tooling
that depends on the hive metastore
things like hive
presto spark impala hootie and many more
there's also an emerging set of open
source that uses the hive metastore
in data lakes things like iceberg and
delta lake
the hive metastore integrates with a lot
of open source that people use as part
of a data lake things like kerberos
ranger atlas and the metastore can
understand or
represent data that's in many different
places things like hadoop clusters
cloud storage bigquery other cloud
providers block storage
elasticsearch clusters kafka clusters
and so on
so to put it simply the hive metastore
is the
central point for open data lakes and
it's a critical path
for any data lake which is built
at least partially on open source so
it's very important that
i've met a store is usable and reliable
so we developed the dataproc metastore
we recently announced that it's in alpha
public availability
and the goal was to have a fully managed
highly available
and open source native apache hive
metastore
we want to provide an apache hive
metastore service
that removes all of the barriers for
using both the hive metastore and the
tooling around the hive metastore
from our point of view if we give you
the best managed spark or flink service
it really falls apart without a
well-managed
hive metastore which is why we developed
the dataproc metastore
it's also really important and i'm going
to underscore this point again that
the dataproc metastore is open source
native we don't want to
limit what people can do with the apache
hive metastore
we want the hive metastore to be highly
usable and often hive metastores sound
simple but their
actual maintenance and operation can be
quite complicated
throughout our design of the data
procurement store we focused on
simplified management
this is an example of creating a new
dataproc metastore
in this case you can see the creation
screen for just creating a metastore
you can see that we only require a few
simple options things like
name the metastore version where you
want to create that metastore
whether you want kerberos to be enabled
or not this makes getting started with
the hive meta store very very
easy essentially one click
likewise we want the hive metastore to
be very compatible
so if you have an existing hive
metastore we want it to be very easy for
you to bring your data to the dataproc
metastore
in this example we have the import
functionality
this allows you to take an existing hive
metastore and import it
into a dataproc metastore so
it should be easy to create a new
metastore and play around with the hive
metastore and its tooling if you're a
new user
or if you're already deeply embedded and
invested in the hive metastore ecosystem
it should be very easy to migrate to use
the dataprop
metastore throughout the design
and implementation of the dataproc
metastore we've wanted to
create a service which is flexible
integrated
and reliable in terms of flexibility
as you're using the dataproc metastore
if you want to for example scale your
metastore up
because you have more users or you have
added more tooling which uses the hive
metastore
we want it to be very easy for you to
manage that metastore
the resources who can control uh who has
access to the meta store how it works
things like that
we also want that metastore to be
integrated as i
mentioned previously the hive metastore
sits at the center of an
open data ecosystem so it's really
important that the metastore
works with a lot of things out of the
box
as an example we've worked with clebra
and kuble to make sure
that they work out of the box with the
dataproc metastore
there are two examples but they showcase
that we're very focused on making sure
that the
proc meta store is open and integrated
meta stores are also very difficult to
run because they are a critical path
in your ecosystem if the meta store goes
down
often many things break so it's
important to us
that the dataproc metastore is reliable
and from the ground up we've designed
the dataproc metastore so it's
highly reliable
there's another really interesting
feature which i want to showcase
up front today and that is the dataproc
hub
let's start with two personas on one
hand you have a data scientist
and on the other you have an i.t
administrator and say that both of these
people or personas work for the same
organization
they have different needs the data
scientist wants to create notebooks that
are building blocks they want to create
models they want to tinker and
experiment and explore with data
and often data scientists want to do
this in a way that's unimpeded
so they want to be able to create a
notebook and use tooling
and often data scientists are
preferential to
frameworks and tooling so they just want
to get started and hands-on with data
on the other you have i.t administrators
who are concerned about things like
making sure that
code is production ready and
productionized property
they also care about costs and controls
and security
things that the data scientists might
not have
front and center in mind when they want
to get started with
a notebook what this usually means is
that when a data scientist wants to
create a notebook create a model and
then get something in production
it can take weeks if not months and
require a lot of steps
in between we think that
things should be much much easier the
data scientists should be able to
create a notebook and then take that
notebook
and have it turn into production ready
code or productionalize their notebook
as easily as possible
in essence notebooks should be easy
configurable
and all in one place there shouldn't be
a lot of steps
there shouldn't be a lot of friction and
there shouldn't be a lot of
organizational frustration and trying to
both enable notebooks and also control
them at the same time
so we built dataproc hub we recently
announced dataproc hub in open beta
and dataproc hub is built in conjunction
with the ai platform notebooks
functionality on google cloud platform
ultimately what this means is that we
are bringing data scientists and i.t
administrators together
and we're also bringing notebooks
together with ai
platform tools and dataproc as a result
data scientists can easily create
notebooks
they can choose their favorite open
source toolkits and frameworks
and they can use advanced features on
google cloud platform on dataproc
clusters things like gpus
or ssds if they have workloads that are
iops performant
what this means for it administrators is
that they can predefine
who can do what with notebooks what the
size and shape
of data clusters looks like what
features are automatically enabled or
disallowed
it also makes it very easy for these it
administrators to see exactly who's
using notebooks
and then take what's being done and
productionalize it very very
easily the it administrator story is
really important to us as we think about
notebook use and as the first
it's an optional but as a first step an
i.t administrator can pre-define
who can do what with dataproc up
specifically what this means is
an it administrator can predefine what
size
shape location and features are used in
a dataproc cluster that powers
a dataproc hub notebook that way once
somebody gets their jupiter-based
dataproc hub notebook
all of the constraints are automatically
applied for the cluster that runs and
powers that notebook
in this example we have a yaml-based
cluster configuration
that specifies an idle configuration so
in this case the cluster would be
deleted if it was idle for more than
7200 seconds
an id administrator can use this
configuration
as a template for clusters that are then
used for dataproc hub notebooks
so if a cluster is idle it automatically
gets deleted
and this showcases how we're trying to
bring both data scientists
and i.t administrators together with
dataproc up
ultimately the flow of using a notebook
with dataproc hub and ai platform
notebook
should be fairly easy the data scientist
can go look for examples or snippets in
a
ai notebooks platform or go directly to
dataproc hub
to create new notebooks or reuse
existing notebooks
then they can use that notebook and
dataproc or
bigquery to prepare process
create models data sets all the while
the it administrator
can see who's doing what with notebooks
they can pre-configure
the boundaries on what notebooks can do
and the clusters that
underlie them and then they can do
things like schedule and manage
notebooks that have already been created
by dataproc hub
ultimately this is showcasing that it
can be a frictionless process
between data scientists and i.t
administrators it also makes it very
easy to
create data proc clusters with
jupiter-based dataproc hub notebooks for
data scientists so there's
fewer hoops to jump through when you
want to do data science
so in this case i'm going to show you
what a quick demonstration of dataproc
hub
looks like to show you why it's really
easy to get started
with dataproc hub to do data science
with open source tools
so in this example i am a data scientist
and i want to maybe use spark and
bigquery
so i know i can go to ai hub and find
some examples for
common situations in this case i'm going
to see if there's an example for how to
use spark
with bigquery together so i search
for bigquery here and i will get a list
of results
and in the results i can see that there
is indeed a quick example showing how to
use spark with bigquery
this is using the spark bigquery
connector that's provided on dataproc
i then can take that example and open it
in the ai platform notebooks and i
already have a pre-configured workbench
that an it administrator has
pre-configured for me
i then sign in so dataproc hub does
perform the authorization and
authentication checks
and you can see that the cluster that is
behind this notebook has been already
pre-configured by the it administrator
so as a data scientist all i need to do
is just click start
this creates the notebook it also
creates the cluster that powers the
notebook behind the scenes
you can see in this example that all the
data scientists had to do
was click start and they got the
notebook and the cluster
they don't have to think about
configuration they don't have to think
about networking plumbing or cluster
options
the data scientist doesn't even
necessarily have to know what dataproc
is
all they did was create a notebook and
get started
beyond dataproc hub i want to talk
through some of the really
important open source updates that we've
provided on dataproc
in the last several months we make it a
point to keep up with the latest
and greatest in open source and we're
really passionate about
bringing new open source developments to
you in dataproc
as a managed service one of the big
advancements that i want to showcase
is dataproc 2 which just entered public
preview
dataproc 2 includes some significant
upgrades in the default components that
we install
on dataproc clusters what this means is
you get
hadoop3 spark3 hive 31
java 11 and several other upgrades to
components that we put on clusters by
default
we keep the number of components that we
install by default
somewhat slimmed down so you have
efficient clusters and we narrow the
installs down to the most used
components
but there's still a whole set of things
you can install
on dataproc clusters through
initialization actions
custom images optional components and
other means
these optional installs have also been
updated in dataproc image 2.
so it includes things like apache flink
updates to apache hbase
druid presto and others so dataproc
2 is a brand new image line in dataproc
designed to bring the hadoop 3 and
spark3 ecosystem
to you i specifically want to talk about
spark 3 because spark 3 includes a
number of
really interesting and important updates
that we're
excited both to bring you in dataproc
and we're very interested in
seeing how we can bring these
functionalities and improvements to
future dataproc features
so the theme for spark3 was performance
and there's three good examples of what
that means
for you in terms of performance in spark
3.
first spark 3 includes better adaptive
query support
so spark can optimize a query plan while
things are executing
spark 3 also has dynamic partition
printing so
unnecessary scans are avoided in queries
that
could look like data warehouse queries
so again faster querying
spark 3 also has improved gpu
support and we're really excited because
we think there's a future where spark 3
could run
entirely on gpus both for data science
and potentially just general data
processing so
we're very interested in seeing what the
future holds for spark and gpus
there's also a lot of advancements for
spark running on
kubernetes i'll talk about it in just a
bit
but dataproc has a flavor which allows
you to run spark on kubernetes clusters
that are managed by dataproc
so we're very excited to see new
advancements in kubernetes and spark
because it will
only make both the spark community
better
but also makes dataproc a much more
interesting product from a kubernetes
perspective
i mentioned gpus before but this is
something that's that's really really
exciting to us
and we've worked closely with nvidia to
make sure that
gpus work well in spark and also that
gpus work well on gcp and dataproc
clusters
so you can create dataproc clusters with
nvidia gpus today
we've also worked with nvidia on things
like the rapids frameworks to make sure
that you can do really high performance
data processing and data science on
dataproc clusters
if you're interested in using spark3
with gpus
i would highly encourage you to look at
the documentation on the dataproc site
and also the rapids framework
we think this is a really interesting
avenue for spark and open source
in the long term to run on gpus
it's very easy to get started with
dataproc 2 today
all you need to do is specify that you
want to run the preview
of dataproc so this is an example of a
cloud sdk command or gcloud
that specifies the preview image i also
want to call out how easy it is to use
different sets of open source components
on dataproc clusters
you don't have to think about upgrading
one whole cluster to new versions of
spark or hadoop
if you want to try out a new version of
spark in this case spark3
create a very small new cluster and use
the preview image
try a job out try some of the new
features out then you can delete the
cluster when you're done
dataproc imaging is a subtle feature but
makes it very
very easy and interesting to try out
different sets and versions of open
source components
without fear of breaking clusters that
are running production or
high value jobs there's also a whole set
of new dataproc features that i want to
run you through as well
as i mentioned we have a flavor of
dataproc which runs
on kubernetes we recently announced
dataproc
on kubernetes engine clusters in beta
what this means is that you can run
spark jobs with dataproc
on gke clusters we are really excited
about the future
of running open source on kubernetes
clusters
i'll give you three examples of why one
we think
that it allows better resource
management so you can have multiple
things running on one cluster and be
a little bit more sure that resources
are being balanced and managed properly
it also allows you to take one
kubernetes cluster and run open source
data processing with something like a
web application
if you were so inclined it also
potentially allows for better job
isolation
and as customers get better resource
management
job isolation is something that goes
hand in hand
we're also really interested in both
seeing
and helping these open source frameworks
and toolkits work with some of the more
advanced and interesting features on
kubernetes things like auto scaling node
healing
and the like because that allows for
more dynamic clusters over time
the dataproc team has been involved in
getting both spark and flink working
on kubernetes last year we released both
an operator for spark
and kubernetes because it's a common
question i do want to call out that we
will support both yarn
and kubernetes well into the future of
dataproc we're not
making a wholesale decision to switch
from one to the other
we see customers over the next several
years will want to use both
for different reasons and we have a plan
to support both yarn and kubernetes well
into the future another feature that i'm
really
excited to mention is dataproc flex mode
i'll explain flex mode through a problem
with both scaling
and virtual machines when you're trying
to scale down you may hold on to
a node or a set of nodes because they
have intermediate data they've finished
processing
they're just holding on to something
that they can't get rid of but otherwise
you would get rid of the node
likewise with preemptables you may have
a node that's finished
processing or reached a state where it
can checkpoint
but the node is preempted in both cases
if you removed the node you would lose
the data
flex mode is a stateful data store that
allows you to store
stateful data such as mapreduce shuffle
data in hdfs
on the cluster this makes clusters more
flexible because you can add
and remove clusters much more easily
without interrupting your job
so in my example if you wanted to scale
down once the node's done
computing it can put all of its data in
flexpool
and then the node can simply be auto
scaled down
likewise if you lose a preemptable vm
that's finished processing
that preemptable vm has already put its
data in the flex pool so its preemption
presents no risk to your job flex mode
should allow better auto scaling
and also should allow you to use more
preemptables in your dataproc clusters
which again means greater flexibility
and cost optimization
there's two new security features which
adding to the
pile of pre-existing data proc security
features
so dataproc already allows you to use
security features such as
ranger customer managed and customer
supplied encryption keys
kerberos vpc service controls
our component gateway which allows you
to access web uis with no networking
it still provides authorization all of
these are great but customers have told
us they want
more security which we've been squarely
focused on and these are two of multiple
new security features which you'll see
in the future
one of the security features is secure
extensions for notebooks
what this means is that you can give
somebody a notebook
and that someone or that data scientist
for example
their credentials will be used for
execution of the job
and to communicate with whatever
services that job
connects with so for example if i am a
data scientist
and i interact with cloud storage my
data scientists individual credentials
be used to go talk to cloud storage
instead of a service account and this
brings better per
user isolation and security to notebooks
a second feature that we recently
announced was shielded vms
so if you're using dataproc clusters
with uh ubu218 or debian 10
you can use shielded vms again
these are two new out of future
security improvements that you'll
continue to see in dataproc to
make sure that customers have all of the
security features both that they
might want but also that we could
potentially offer as a cloud provider
i want to finally mention uh something
that doesn't get a lot of attention but
is a
kind of a continual feature in dataproc
and that's additional compute
flexibility
every time there's a new region or a new
vm type
or new accelerator accelerator we try to
wire those through to dataproc as
quickly as possible
what this means is you get new levers
for cost
and speed optimization in this example
say that you had a workload which was
performance insensitive and you just
wanted to lower your cost
you could use e2 machine types to lower
your cost relative to maybe you are
running on
n1 standard forms you can see in the
table all of the vms kind of look and
feel the same but the cost is different
this is an example of how additional
compute flexibility can give you some
really powerful levers to
speed things up or to optimize costs
depending on
your needs finally i want to talk about
how you can get started with
dataproc the best place to get started
with dataproc
is our documentation on the google cloud
site we also have a set
of tutorials on the dataproc site things
like using spark with bigquery or
creating clusters to run
presto so you should be able to run
through those tutorials to understand
dataproc and some of the open source
tooling pretty quickly
if you're brand new to google cloud i
really encourage you to take a look at
the
free trial for google cloud platform to
get started with both google cloud
and also databrock if you're curious
about dataproc you're an existing
dataproc
customer and want to know more or
participate
we have a stackoverflow tag google cloud
dataproc
which you can use to find questions and
ask new questions
often you'll see the dataproc
engineering team trying to help
customers and stack overflow users
we also have a google group cloud
dataproc discuss
and a feedback email list and please do
send us your feedback and thoughts it's
customers that
largely influence and help drive our
roadmap so
we are passionate on hearing and
responding to our customers and whatever
needs
you may have with that i want to thank
you very much for your time
and have a great day